[Music]
read me k20 Pro depending on who you are
you've either heard a ton of hype around
this for a while now or this is
literally the first time you're ever
hearing about it right now I feel like
this phone picks up right where the
polka phone left off it's very similar
to the polka phone in more ways than one
but instead of just nailing a few key
specs for a super low price this
red-meat k20 pro feels like a super
complete all-around basically flagship
level phone it has essentially
everything for 400 bucks and that's why
it's blowing up it's definitely more
expensive than the 300 dollar polka
phone which is absolutely crazy but this
in this package is definitely a better
more all-around phone you'll see what I
mean but first I want to address the
whole naming scheme so when I was first
put onto this phone you guys put it on
my radar a lot of tweets at me a lot of
emails asking me to review red-meat k20
Pro so I look it up and it looks like
this so I looked out on my desk and I
already have this phone right here so
I'm like oh I already have a k20 Pro
except it's not it says says me on the
back and it came in a box from Xiaomi
that said Xiaomi me 90 there's a couple
other slightly different things about it
but they look nearly identical so I look
up the specs of this mean 90 to see how
similar they are it's essentially
exactly the same as the k20 Pro but with
a snapdragon 730 but then I unbox it and
I log in to my Google account on it and
it says welcome to your read me K 20
which is making me even more confused
but then I finally do get the read me K
20 Pro turns out the K 20 Pro is just an
upgraded version of the K 20 this has
the Snapdragon 855 the K 20 has a
Snapdragon 730 which has a global
version called the Xiaomi me 90 which is
an upgraded version of the Xiaomi me 9
if you follow all of that but none of
that really matters what matters is the
K 20 Pro
deserves the attention is getting
because it legitimately tries to include
literally everything you could possibly
expect out of a flagship but out of
lower price
now it's not all the highest-quality it
definitely has a quantity it has almost
everything but it's still a 400 ollar
phone so aesthetically first of all it's
pretty unique looking with the colors
sort of dancing down the sides and then
depending on how the light hits it this
shimmery pattern changes it's pretty
cool but it's actually also still glass
and still a fingerprint magnet but this
thing is already starting off with a leg
up you typically expect budget phones to
have plastic and cheap materials this
one is legit metal and glass USB type-c
you got it a slight curve to the bag
glass you got it
headphone jack you got that a
full-screen display from top to bottom
thin bezels you got it pop-up selfie
camera you got it a built-in LED light
fingerprint reader underneath the glass
you got that too four thousand milliamp
power battery you got that Snapdragon
855 it's all here pretty much the only
hardware thing this guy is missing if
you're comparing it to flagships is
water resistance and wireless charging
so you know it is a glass back with no
wireless charging I've said before if
you're gonna do that just go with a high
quality plastic so you avoid being
breakable but oh well
so like I've said the list of things
that this phone has as you've heard is
kind of amazing but the actual quality
of all these different things varies not
all specs are created equal the natural
place to start as a display and it's
pretty nice to be honest it's a six
point four inch 1080p AMOLED no notch
thin bezels and it's pretty bright its
visible outdoors with fairly decent
colors maybe a little big if anything
but we're so used to seeing so many
budget phones with either big chins and
big bezels or smaller screens or notches
this one's just clean and it's flat so
I'm reminded again of how much I liked
this versus the displays that sort of
spill over the sides so I really like
this screen to me this is the best
display in any mid-range phone and then
underneath that display glass there is a
fingerprint reader which again that's
pretty impressive for a mid-range er at
the fact that it's there in the first
place but this reader itself it's not
that fast so you can kind of get used to
it it's a little bit of a delay when you
press it but it's in this weird place
where it's slower than most other in
glass
fingerprint readers on great phones but
also slower than the capacitive ones are
used to but at least it's cooler it's
under the screen and then like we've
also seen lately to achieve the full
screen design pop-up selfie camera and
this one has a light on it I don't know
if that achieves anything other than
looking kind of cool but the mechanism
is decently fast it's rated for 300,000
opens and closes you can't use it for
RGB face unlock but I don't recommend
that and it even has automatic freefall
detection so if you're taking a selfie
and you drop the phone and it has a
freefall it actually closes the camera
app and shuts it to avoid damage if it
lands on it but a low-key pretty
important part of it is that light in
the selfie camera actually shines
through the top of it so it can act as a
sort of a notification LED so you can
see if you're plugged in and charging it
lights up to tell you and when you're
finished charging that changes really
the only thing I don't like about this
selfie camera is the photos it takes
which are straight garbage like this is
possibly the worst selfie camera I can
remember using since I started to review
phones there's absolutely no dynamic
range colours are pretty terrible at a
very very soft detail yes beauty mode is
off like I just don't know why it's this
bad but you know what makes it even more
crazy how good the back cameras are this
k20 Pro again has yet another flagship
looking spec an array of triple cameras
on the back a 48 megapixel main camera
an 8 megapixel telephoto and a 13
megapixel ultra wide so that main sensor
is a Sony it's an amx 586 so it's the
same sensor that we've seen in a couple
other
honor and vivo phones that have
performed pretty well it'll shoot 4k
60fps video with any of the camera
lenses so yes you can shoot video with
the ultra wide camera unlike the 1 plus
7 Pro it'll even shoot 960 FPS
slow-motion now it's not high resolution
at all but you know definitely more of a
gimmick but that's still pretty cool and
then for photos I was of course
expecting maybe some average photos some
that maybe look better if they're in
great light and I was very impressed
obviously if you give it a ton of light
you're going to get the best out of the
sensor and this stayed true HDR was
working pretty great but even the ultra
wide camera was giving me some nice
shots the
every production wasn't too
oversaturated or overdone with the
processing sometimes you see too much
sharpening in these phones that wasn't
here I was more impressed often than I
thought I would be it's not the fastest
camera in the world but overall the
image quality not bad and even at night
like in in dark environments where you
expect it to fall apart yeah it totally
does the noise reduction goes super
overboard and everything is super soft
and it looks terrible but if you happen
to have a subject that will sit still
for you and you turn on night mode you
get some of your sharpness back and the
dynamic range actually improves like
that's that's that's pretty good that's
not bad so really the only thing left is
using the phone every day and again like
I said technically on paper it has all
those things you'd expect from a
flagship snapdragon a 55 six or eight
gigs of ram and up to 256 gigs of
storage so it's running MIUI 10 on top
of Android Pi and this is not my first
choice but it's growing on me so
aesthetically this is why it's not my
favorite but functionally it's not
lacking at all the app drawer with the
search bar at the bottom is nice for
each ability it actually has a nice
clean brightness slider that I've liked
for a while it's like always available
but the glassiness of it all and the the
icons just certain things are a little
too much for me and that's kind of their
aesthetic right now but overall
performance I'd say it was about a B and
this is something I actually expect it
to be better when you have these
high-end specs but the animations
weren't really smooth all the time I got
occasional hiccups with the keyboard and
with opening stuff minor things but
stuff you don't really expect to see
from a phone with a 1080p display and a
high-end chip so it's still fast but not
really that smooth if that makes sense
but that battery though that four
thousand milliamp hour battery they put
in this phone gives it a battery life
that is right up to par with the other
flagship sometimes better than the 1 + 7
/ I've been using and not only does it
have a really large battery and support
fast charging but it also comes with a
fast charger in the box
and it has this sweet charging animation
so the battery life situation is pretty
great on this phone look I'm going to
tell you right now for the price
red-meat K 20 pro is a great phone it
I think it gets you the closest to
forgetting that you spent half what you
could have spent on a high-end phone it
gets you the closest to that but a lot
of this is easy to just point out on
paper when you actually use it there are
certain things that keep reminding you
that it is a cheaper phone the vibration
motor for example pretty cheap pretty
loose not very good and when you feel
that all the time you're reminded also
the single mono speaker at the bottom is
super easy to block and that's pretty
bad so if you do audio all the time
you're reminded the selfie camera like I
talked about is just absolutely
comically awful and even little things
like the slower fingerprint reader you
might not know it's slow if you haven't
used a more expensive phone but I
definitely did notice it but for the
most part the important stuff the big
stuff your specs your overall solid
build quality your solid performance the
headphone jack is a nice touch and the
display being better than I expected
sort of fits this where the polka phone
left off which is a really really great
value and kind of like that polka phone
even if you never buy this redmi k20 pro
or even the xiaomi me 90 this is still a
testament to how good these mid-range
and budget phones have gotten lately so
maybe I can't say good phones are
getting cheap anymore maybe we'll put a
little strikeout through that one but I
definitely can say cheap phones are
getting good and I'm glad this one
exists to be a part of that movement
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys the next one peace